hello i'm gab i'm dan we're the slo-mo
guys and today
we are without lab coats well we've got
these lovely things instead it's true
we're also without our phones
uh so there's no microphones but
hopefully that one's doing all right
we're here at the colorado school of
mines
and what we gonna be doing daniel well
with when you're mining you need to use
explosives a lot of the time yeah right
so that's what we're going to be doing
we're going to be using
a shovel exactly except for instead of
using it for mining we're going to be
using it for slow-mo guys purposes
yeah which involves a toilet
a safe some mannequins some mannequins
some mannequins are gonna bite it
plenty of explosives we also have an
absolute myriad of phantoms to get an
absolute range of
resolution and frame rates so uh let's
have a blast
because of the puns and stuff
i've destroyed a few bogs in my time you
do like your spicy food it's true yeah
but now we're literally gonna destroy a
bog okay
right this is pretty savage so we're
gonna have
det cord coming around and up into the
cistern which is going to be full of
petrol
and then the detonation train will go
down here into this five pound booster
charge of high explosives which is gonna
detonate and
cause a shock wave and hopefully destroy
the bog
so you've taken care of all the
explosive putting
and over here in this giant metal
protective box we've got two phantom
v2512s
this one is set to 28 500 frames a
second this one is set to 207
000 frames a second so it's very low
resolution but
very very fast also up there in that
yellow box
we've got a v2640 which will be hd
about 12 000 frames a second
all right let's watch that back oh whoa
oh where's the toilet it's just
i didn't see a single piece not one
piece i just saw a big
white bright flash it was so bright
maybe it went out the back
whoa and all of this white cloud here
is all petrol so did we not see it from
the other angle because
the cloud covered it and now we're
seeing the fireball here yeah i think oh
maybe it just went up look at it all
lighting up now
it looks cool look at all this all of
that
is lighting up now look at it expand oh
man that's
so scary i'll tell you what the dynamic
range on this camera is
not bad like it's pretty much held all
of those highlights
even though we're at such a high iso you
know what's also really cool is often
you don't see
a big flaming explosion with rubble
going everywhere it's not
just a flaming
well that's where the toilet was it's
i think there's no pieces of it left
it's literally dust it has been entirely
eviscerated
it's dug pretty much a crater and
cleared the area of stones completely
so this is not worried about it what's
up there with those guys
whoa oh
i'm touching it cheers for that
next experiment this is a the beefiest
safe we could find for 150
i think it's about 150 years old as well
i like we paid 150
for a safe that doesn't work yeah we're
just trying to
get into the safe like if you imagine if
you're a bank robber
uh we're going to try and just blow a
hole through the door yeah this safe
seems to have lost most of its concrete
yeah but uh we've got this barrel here
to see hopefully we'll see it coming to
there
yeah so what we've got here is a shaped
charge
it looks funny because it's got a copper
cone inside and packed in behind the
copper cone
is explosives this is the decor it's
what we'll use to initiate it
so explosion will come down the deck
chord down here
hit the back of the shaped charge and
the explosive explosion the detonation
will start at the back
and travel forwards what that'll do is
force this copper cone into an
inverse jet so it will the back part
here right the back
will come out here before this this part
even gets hit and it will form a jet
and that's used to penetrate things like
tanks armor or
safes or anything like that and the
correct you have to have something
called standoff and that's
six times the diameter of the cone which
means that that's about 23 centimeters
24 centimeters away from what you're
going to penetrate because that's the
is the width is about four centimeters
so if you if you had it too close
too close effective it wouldn't be as
efficient the copper jet wouldn't have
reached
peak like penetration capability
i've never seen a shape charge in
slow-mo neither have i actually not like
a
not properly because they're usually
part of like
oh it was absolutely
instant what all right wind that back
hold on
it's it's honestly like when a meteor
enters the atmosphere and you just
you're watching a big ball of light
coming through the air it's the same
sort of speed as well i feel like the
cop has already gone
into the water and then when we spin on
you'll see that miles later the barrel
comes up
oh i just love how directional this
explosive is i mean that's what it does
literally nothing went anywhere else
[Music]
oh perfect look at that oh
hang on so it went into the barrel but
it didn't come out the other side which
means there must be some copper at the
bottom
that was it right through but it's
annihilated all the concrete around it
it's like
you see all this concrete here yeah that
was in the safe and this lock
oh it's completely hanging off look
perfect little hole
oh man
look at that i know we say this a lot
but
like it's nothing it's just excuse me
seriously oh solid metal did i just go
through something so
all of the shape charges i've used
before in the military have been solid
copper lining yeah whereas this is an
oil and gas
shaped charge and it's actually made of
copper powder so there won't be any
solid bits of copper anywhere and you
can see here that's what that is
that's what that is that's the
smattering of copper powder and before
when you when you
ones that are used against tanks and
things you can actually see
the copper that's left over in the hole
it makes because it's
solid copper so we've got doris
and frank here who are retired
mannequins
well i've noticed that doris's fingers
come off yeah that's why she was retired
she had an industrial accident
this is a shock tube yeah and it has
inside it's called a
dust explosion which travels down the
tube at about 2000 meters a second
and that's enough to initiate a
detonator which is then enough to
initiate
decor which is what it's used for but
what we're going to do is trail it all
the way
from where we are all the way down
swirling around
it's going to come to doris here we're
going to wrap it all the way around
doris
like this down to the bottom where we're
gonna hit a detonator
into some decor which is then gonna wrap
all the way back around her
around her here and then that will
actually explode and hopefully sort of
obliterate her because this is just sort
of
quite safe it won't do anything to her
and then
the debt cord this is quite long and
it's going to travel from her neck
all the way down to here where we're
going to have a shaped charge
which is then going to go through what's
his name frank through frankie
frank through frank and then we've got
some foam canisters on the other side
that will hopefully explode when the the
copper jet manages to get through
so this is a huge chain reaction of a
bunch of different types of explosives
it's an explosive train it's what it's
called so you start small with something
like this
and you're going to prime explosives
with detonator and then into decor and
then it's a main charge so this time i'm
going to
set the exposure on the phantoms much
lower so we don't get as much white out
from the deckboard explosions get more
detail here don't look up her skirt
i was looking into her finger oh you're
looking at my look at my skirt from here
dan this is a special occasion yeah
because we've got a return
of a very rare guest on the slimmer guys
it's other
rivaled that's right it's rival dance
this is a little bit of an awkward
situation having both of us here at the
same time
you may not recognize dan because in
this video he has a shirt on for once
explosives and bare chests just doesn't
work out
so then this one here will be the edge
we
start from that'll go up the stairs see
this little symbol here that's where
we're going to pop the deck cord in that
little cradle
yeah so it's enough explosive force to
initiate the shape charge which is going
to blast its way through frank
this is an absolute operation there just
it's just so nerve racking to watch your
decor
on your head basically i mean it's
perfectly safe you can chew it and it
wouldn't do anything
i was i had a taste earlier it's called
secondary explosive
better to be safe than sorry i think so
that's the shock tube right there
it's racing along so quick it looks fake
isn't it it's gonna be like a little
disco happening here
i like the little switch
it's like she's in the most dangerous
nightclub ever do you think that the
deck chord
because it was wrapped so tight around
the head it all just went at once around
the head yes what do you think because
it would be sympathetic
detonation so yeah one of the layers
would have got the next one
the shape charge beats the shock wave
yeah it's insane
i deliberately made this one much much
darker because we're shooting much much
slower but we should actually see the
shock tube travel
almost at a leisurely pace at this frame
rate
oh here we go it's gone down the legs
shouldn't be coming any second oh where
are we oh
there we go i think it's just oh
the step up in speed is so insane
because you see the shock tube going
only two thousand meters a second but
the
deck cord is then going at seven
thousand it's a huge step up and that
shape charge that
looks like a damn rocket going off it's
getting about 10 000 meters a second
and when you were describing the shape
charge i thought it would be more like a
shotgun where it would just kind of blow
all in one direction
but it's so narrow and so specific like
you could
you could shoot someone with it yeah for
sure you could shoot it right at someone
and it might miss it's like a neat it's
like an explosive needle
oh there's a hand oh that was that good
hand oh was that a
safe hand that's a shame she's had a
hell of a retirement party there
look at what it's done to her dress the
decor has just like crisped it up
de-dressed look what the shape charge
did to this guy
it completely sawn him in half oh
totally
honestly when i saw him in half here i
thought that this part had just come off
yeah same but then it's still connected
actually it's still connect this is just
loose oh he's just taking him in half
here's all the foam that caught fire oh
yeah no it didn't actually get
the other one look oh it didn't get that
one it just completely blew his front
out
his front fell off his front fell off to
get uh doris's head to fall off
by wrapping it in deck cord and it i saw
it from over there
pop up about 30 40 feet and then it
landed
just here her head's intact
oh i blew one of her eye sockets off oh
no oh
that's gruesome a splintered server you
should keep that
the head yeah use it as like a i mean
surely though if i try and take it home
when they try and swab it they'd be like
i think there's a small amount of
explosives there so you just say to tsa
you're just like well yeah it blew up
yeah yeah
blew it off obviously are you using this
as an
another opportunity to blow up some of
our merch yeah all right
oh it's a woman blow it out oh dear this
is a nice
t-shirt right get a raffle run out of
this you're kidding
we're happy with this all right looks
like we're good
what do you think that's lovely so we've
made what can only be described as
a monstrosity or some sort of secret
weapon
let me talk you through this we've got
an avalanche these are used
to fire into avalanches into snow sorry
to
force an avalanche so it's not dangerous
yeah that leads down into this huge
fat tube which reaches all the way down
to the floor which is filled
full of ammonium nitrate fuel oil
granular they look like what you fill a
bean bag with except they explode
that's exact that's exactly what it
looks like and then round behind it you
got two five pound boosters
and this is all connected with about six
foot of decor so it's about
50 or more pounds of explosives here
we've also put a third mannequin up the
back
yeah we checked her back there just to
see if what the effects were
compared to obviously this guy's going
to get viscera and i think that one's
probably not going to see much though
i'll see there
that one i wonder how much will be left
all right let's get the hell out of here
remember how this place used to look
before we did that experiment
oh look at the back wall it's just
painted
oh god all right hold on hold on guys
let me get started hold on hold on it's
just like it's been a hurricane here it
just
blew everything away look at the camera
oh my god oh my god we got a phantom
down
blew the window open look if it wasn't
right
no
[Applause]
do you think we have the footage from
that i hope so
back there it looked like a nuke it was
so bright initially you couldn't see
anything like how would you expose for
that initial explosion
uh you could do it but you'd have to you
probably wouldn't see anything
you just see nothing to start with
oh that looks like the end of the world
oh you can see
oh there's like a sparks sparks and
flashes from the uh
or it's usually the rock or maybe just
fast-moving plastic fast enough where
it's actually
igniting on him it honestly looks like
that was fired from a fat man it does
that's what it looks like in fallout and
then once you see the shock wave go up
you see it moving across all this floor
back here see it's got up there and then
it's
lifting up all of the dirt and now it's
imploding back down
there's not quite the camera camera yeah
that might be one of the best and most
well-defined shock waves i've ever
seen it looks like a pyroclastic flow
from a
from a volcano it's just water yeah
and then through the window bash the
camera out onto the floor i can't think
of any time that i would have seen
any explosion that was that big that
close i've certainly never
seen anything like that so this is the
explosion proof
camera shelter i feel like they've never
done an explosion this big here i think
they're all the same ones i feel like
they've definitely never done just
knocked everything
miles we were like this we were like hey
you can get bigger but look what it did
to this housing
no way it's blown it in it like crippled
it
front ways look at that it was there and
it shoved it
it's like it's like ripped it like a tin
can what is interesting
is that it chucked mud so far like look
at our old barrel with the hole in look
at where that was oh it's got another
hole in it
god the thing that even here you would
have been absolutely murdered by that
so the 2640 which was up on the hill
is it also got caked in mud i wonder how
up there
well how quickly the mud caked the view
of the camera there
oh you would see i put such a wide lens
on it
this is the left hand manikin that was
here it was previously about here that
was the one that wasn't the closest yeah
and he's turned to paste
i honestly don't know if we can show
this this is a bit graphic but look
so this lady was stood here about i
don't know five six meters away
yeah she got picked up by the explosion
about
another four meters back the legs off
both her arms are off that just shows
the massive amount of difference between
evisceration
a couple bits left and then like you
know most of it left
i can't believe it blew in our safety
it's because he put the charge behind
the water that's the that's the thing in
in eod you it's called a disruptor you
place explosive charges behind water
and it basically just messes up
everything that's in front of the water
really quickly so he's placed the charge
behind the water and the water's just
gone
straight into the camera shelter and
that's what's done that
let's try and find a piece of your
slo-mo guy shirt this is it
was that it that's it it's like coated
that
oh it's the rooster teeth oh hold that
up that's great
look at that it's the rooster's heat
thing er teeth
oh no it's 30 30
30 30
well do you know my least favorite part
of every snowmobile's videos what's that
well apart from me being hurt
yeah is cleaning up afterwards
but all we've left today is a smoking
crater
well and there's like bits of jeans and
plastic and stuff hey there's no plastic
it's just biodegradable juice that might
be one of the most
mental videos we've ever made it's
insane that was that i think that was a
lot of explosives yeah
well big thanks to vision research for
setting this up
and letting us use their phantoms in an
extremely dangerous environment
and thanks to the colorado school of
mines for letting us come and blow stuff
up here
hopefully you enjoyed that video feel
free to follow us on
social media and stuff subscribe to the
summer guys and we got a second channel
we'll see you next time
i feel like the next video should be
really relaxing in comparison yeah i
think we need something like i don't
know just chill
yeah this was this was a lot